Speaker 1: I want to go back because we're
talking about economics.
I want to go back to something I've been telling
you about for a decade at this point in time.
There are now more sort of mainstream media
outlets taking this topic seriously.
If you go back a really long time, certainly
50 years, you can go back 80.
It starts to become less useful if you go
beyond when the parties switched.
But if you go back 50 years when you have
a Democratic president in the White House,
job growth does better.
People's income and income growth does better
and GDP growth does better.
Now, as always, there is no one.
There are no two or three metrics which tell
you everything you need to know about how
an economy is doing.
You can say, but we need to look at wages,
labor participation, inflation, all these
different things.
Consumer confidence, sure.
But jobs, income and GDP all taken together
are well-accepted metrics of how an economy
is doing.
And they all do better on average when the
president is a Democrat.
I am thrilled and we're linking to this article
that Newsweek is finally talking about this.
They write nearly all major U.S. economic
indicators, including income productivity,
stock prices, jobs and domestic product.
Show growth under democratic presidents compared
to when Republicans are in the White House.
I'm not going to give you all the data again
because we've given it to you so many times.
If you had the choice going back between saying,
Do I want to be in the job market when there's
a Democrat in the White House or a Republican?
Statistically, you would have been better
off when there's a Democrat in the White House
if you had said, I'm going to invest in the
S&P 500 when there's a Democrat in the White
House or a Republican.
If you could pick only the years that one
or the other is in the White House, your investment
return would be dramatically better if you
had invested only in the Democratic years.
Now, remember that stocks in general tend
to go up, so you would have done OK in either
case, but you would have done better when
there was a Democratic president in the White
House.
The New York Times released an analysis on
this, and the economy does better when Democrats
are president by every single metric.
Now, whenever this is presented, whenever
this fact is presented, and it is a fact.
You might not like it.
You might want to explain it away, but it
is a fact we hear many arguments against one
of the arguments we hear is, David, you're
looking at the wrong thing.
Those metrics did better because it was a
Republican controlled House or a Republican
controlled Senate or both.
And the answer is no, there is no clear Partizan
pattern.
When you look at control of the house and
control of the Senate, other than it sometimes
matches what is going on in the Oval Office.
That's not a good argument.
Next argument that's often made is Democrats
just get lucky.
You know what happens?
Republicans have these recessions and they
fix them, and then they leave office.
And then in comes a Democratic president,
and they get all the credit for what a Republican
did.
And there's two answers to that.
The first answer to that is, OK, let's pretend
that what you're saying is true.
Let's give the first six months of any one
president's economic growth to the last guy.
So in other words, what that would mean is
Barack Obama's first six months will give
to George W. Bush, give George W. Bush a little
bit of the credit for the Obama recovery.
It's still favors Democrats.
So even if you kind of put in place a six
month grace period, the numbers still don't
look much better for Republicans.
But maybe the most important thing about this
is if it's true that Democrats are coming
in and experiencing economic recoveries when
they are in the White House, why are there
so many Republican recessions that have to
be fixed during Democratic administrations?
So the analysis is extraordinarily clear.
It's a well-known phenomenon.
And yet this is why you know, we opened the
show today by saying.
Economic reality.
Political reality, you might have an economic
reality.
Politically, it doesn't exist unless people
believe it.
And much the same way there's this.
It's really a meme at this point, it's a selfie.
It almost spreads virally.
There's this idea.
That Republicans are better stewards of the
economy.
There are no statistical sets of data that
you can point to in which that is the case.
Let me know via Twitter.
You can find me at Packman.
Why does this talking point about Republicans
being good for the economy persist so strongly?
Because it does find me on Twitter.
Let me know.
Also, just a quick reminder.
Tuesday, April 19th 6:00 PM Eastern is the
next David Pakman show town hall.
It will be streaming live on Packman Live.
All are welcome.
That's April 19th 6:00 p.m.. Looking forward
to seeing and hearing from many of you.
The David Pakman Show truly, genuinely depends
on your support to do what we do.
We're a community funded program, people who
listen to the show and get a membership or
people who watch some YouTube clips, people
who maybe listen to us on one of our radio
affiliates are just getting the podcast on
our website every single day.
We depend on your support and the best way.
The most direct way to support what we do
is to sign up at joint Packman dot com.
We do an extra show every day for our members.
You also have the ability to gift a membership
to someone else if you don't have anyone to
gift the membership to.
That's OK.
I now have a list of six 615 people who have
asked for memberships, and you can donate
a membership to one of them simply by checking
the box.
This is a gift when you sign up and not sending
it to anyone.
It will then be left to me.
And believe me, I have a few hundred people
who would love to get a membership from you